a new strain of the coronavirus first
discovered in britain and thought to be
more contagious has been found in the
u.s
for the first time officials say the
patient is a man in his 20s who lives in
rural colorado and has no recent travel
history
it's one more problem in the middle of a
massive end of the year
surge more than 201 000 new coveted
cases were reported yesterday
wow along with a record one day total of
3725 deaths
meg oliver is in new york city one of
the hardest hit areas meg good morning
adriana good morning here in the one
time epicenter of the outbreak
hospitalizations have more than doubled
since the beginning of the month
levels not seen since may and things are
looking increasingly grim
nationwide as dr anthony fauci warns the
pandemic
is out of control we're going to have an
increase superimposed upon that surge
which could make january
even worse than december a worst month
of coronavirus is hard to imagine
especially in places like los angeles
county
daily deaths there are up 600 percent
since november
and with icu's completely full the state
extended strict stay-at-home orders on
the southern california region
some hospitals are treating patients in
ambulances and cafeterias
at martin luther king junior community
hospital they've resorted to putting
beds in the gift shop we're 131 bed
hospital that started the day with 224
patients in the hospital with the virus
raging out of control many americans are
desperate to get the vaccine
and the process so far has been slow
there is absolutely no
reason we cannot get vaccines out faster
the american people
dr ashish jaws the dean of brown
university school of public health
there really hasn't been much investment
from the federal side in helping
states to get the vaccines into people's
arms states don't have the dollars and
they don't have the resources to just
figure all of this stuff out on their
own
in florida thousands of seniors lined up
for their shot at the covet vaccine
some waiting overnight it's kind of like
a mob scene
of senior citizens retired school
teacher wayne frangelo spent
hours waiting for information from local
officials about
vaccine registration that he says never
came
he finally booked a slot two weeks from
now
it wasn't on twitter it wasn't on
facebook it wasn't
on the news if you're not good at
sniffing and scurrying you're just out
of luck
dr john told us at the current
vaccination rate it would take
years for us to reach herd immunity but
both he and dr fauci believe
the process will eventually speed up
yesterday health and human services
announced
nearly 20 million doses for distribution
but most of those have yet to be
distributed and
very few have actually been administered
eureka
meg thank you